hidden amongst all the pain and stress
of studying for exams you might find
that physics can actually be a very
beautiful subject whilst physics at
school is often about meeting standards
pleasing examiners or being competitive
real physics and math beyond that can be
rewarding and interesting i recently
made some videos about the very
stressful university entrance exam from
turkey and there was a fair amount of
despair in the comments today i wanted
to show a positive example of
achievement coming out of turkey and i
wanted to do that through telling the
story of faiza garcia who was a very
successful mathematician and physicist
i find him very inspiring because not
only was he working on one of the
hardest ideas in physics but he also
relentlessly pursued all knowledge art
music poetry and beautiful ideas he made
significant contributions to general
relativity and particle physics where he
found symmetries that he expressed using
group theory
some of his work would inspire what
would go on to be called quantum
chromodynamics and garcet was highly
respected by many of the top physicists
to follow his journey let's start with a
school report card
jose was born in istanbul in april 1921
but attended primary school in paris
this report card is from january 1928
so when he was only six years old but he
was already earning the respect of his
teachers
his conduct and order are said to be
good and for reading writing calculation
and spelling
there is place first written in this
column so i guess he was top of his
class there's also a first for grammar
and for recitation
overall he's said to have been doing
very good later he would return to
turkey and become a boarding student at
galatasaray high school this is one of
the enrolment documents there it's got
his name and the number 39 which was
assigned to him his father's name that
he was born in istanbul in 1921 that
he's a boarding student who entered the
school in 1930. this is stamped
1939 when he would have been in the 11th
grade and here is a picture of him at
that time
here's a copy of phaser's report card
from 1939 to 1940. there's nothing too
scandalous to report here in fact it
looks like he was quite a good student
and fairly well-rounded down this column
we have the subjects and then i believe
these are grades from written exams the
first two columns and then an opinion
note and then the overall passing grades
signed off by the teachers there's a lot
of nines and tens here which i believe
to be the highest
the subjects here are literature history
geography
natural sciences all tens
also straight tends for physics and
chemistry and there's foreign language
philosophy mechanics geometry and
algebra the second page would detail any
penalties but he doesn't seem to have
any and this is the attendance these are
the rows for days off and days late and
it's signed by the school directors and
indicates an overall pass
jose graduated from the science
department of this high school in 1940
at the top of his class
and he was said to be a legendary
student who impressed both local and
foreign teachers
it was in high school that he decided to
dedicate his life to physics
a classmate of garcia said that at
school during evening study hours you
could often find phaser reading
philosophical stories named in search of
lost time
this is a long novel that comes in seven
parts and is said to try to find an
answer to some of life's questions such
as who am i and what am i to make of
this life fazer was also said to often
be examining the artworks of cezanne and
phases teachers would often call him
into the teacher lounge during breaks to
chat with him after graduating high
school gosse attended the istanbul
university and graduated with a degree
in physics and math in 1944.
graduated top of his class he found the
curriculum at the science department to
not be challenging enough so still had
plenty of time to nurture his interests
in poetry and art
however he said i have to learn physics
in spite of everything perhaps
indicating that he thought he could
excel in many different fields but felt
the strongest calling towards physics he
went to imperial college in london for
his phd which he received in 1950 with
his thesis titled application of
quaternions to quantum field
while he was a grad student gosei wrote
a letter to his mother which seems to
have come from a time when he was
struggling to make progress but was
still holding on to his motivations
he says
i am not hanging out at parties as you
assume dear mother i work day and night
i have been holding on to the things
that i want to work on for two years
with all my strength general field
theory and relations between
electromagnetic nissan and electron
fields
what i am currently working on cannot go
beyond formalism but i hope that at
least if the cambridge philosophical
society accepts me i can show my
supervisor that i am not wasting all my
time he'd said that he was trying to get
fundamental equations into quaternion
formalism but that is supervisor thought
it was unnecessary and priggish to focus
on quaternions but taking a look at his
thesis published three years later it
does look like he made some good
progress the abstract says that the
object of the thesis is to show that the
quaternion algebra can be applied
successfully to the discussion and
solution of dirac's equation
and that it can be extended to general
relativity to give an invariant
formulation of field equations much of
his work after this focused on group
theory and its application to particle
physics in reality the work that he did
is very advanced and takes a lot of
prior knowledge to understand where it's
coming from but let me give just the
briefest of introductions to group
theory to kind of set the stage for the
space that he was working in but first i
would like to quickly thank short form
looking for ways to increase how much i
can learn from books i came across short
form who have kindly sponsored this
video
short form provides detailed book
summaries of the best nonfiction books
it's a way to take books you've always
wanted to read and learn the key ideas
to a deeper level i wouldn't otherwise
have time to read a lot of these books
in their entirety their categories cover
many topics including philosophy science
and communication
i think the books on communication are
the most useful for my own personal
growth like this one called quiet about
how introverts can embrace their
personality instead of trying to force
themselves to be extroverted to fit in
short form drops new book guides and
articles every week by joining through
my link short form dot com slash tibby's
you'll get five days of unlimited access
and an additional 20 off the annual
subscription so check it out the link
will be down in the description now back
to the group theory here i have a square
and a circle and just looking at these
two shapes the circle could be said to
be more symmetrical because there are
more ways that you could rotate it for
example and it would still look the same
in physics a symmetry is a feature that
remains unchanged under some
transformation
if that transformation is rotation then
the circle has a lot more symmetry than
the square there are an infinity of ways
that i could rotate the circle and still
be left with what i started with however
for the square there are some rotations
that don't leave it unchanged like this
one here in fact only rotations of 90
degrees or multiples of 90 would be
considered symmetrical if we were to
write down the set of symmetries for the
square we'd have 90 180 270 and 360. but
one of these rotations is special a
rotation by
360 degrees would have us ending up back
where we started which is the same as a
rotation by zero degrees we call this
the identity element since it does
remain unchanged adding any of these
rotations will give you another rotation
in the set for example 90 plus 180 is
equal to 270.
also every rotation here can be undone
if you've done a rotation of 270 and
want to undo it you can do an additional
rotation of 90 because 270 plus 90 is
360 and that's the identity the second
rotation would be considered the inverse
of the first one and an inverse exists
for every single element
all these properties of these rotations
that i have mentioned are actually
properties of what in maths is called a
group and this set of rotations is just
one example of a group the symmetries of
the circle are also a group but this
time the elements of the group are
infinite and correspond to each possible
angle of rotation in particle physics
there is a group called su-3 which is
very similar to the symmetries of a
sphere and physicists have used
representations of this group to come up
with structures of subatomic particles
there is a lot of symmetry that exists
within the standard model and often
these strange new particles are
predicted before we find them in the lab
because we can see there is a gap or
something missing in the symmetry if you
want to go further into this i'll link
to the ideas of league groups down in
the description
but this was all to show you the basic
idea which faiza gerzi was working in
and the kinds of topics that he was
expanding with his work group theory is
one of the many areas in physics where
you can follow this quote
beauty is truth truth beauty in the
sense that pursuing symmetries and what
seems to work to make the equations
simple and beautiful can lead you to
what is true it isn't always the case
but often it seems to lead you in the
right direction some of faisa girzi's
most important contributions include
this paper
on the symmetries of strong and weak
interactions published in 1960 he also
proposed something called su-6 symmetry
for baryons and mesons he also applied
group theory to scattering of particles
and to general relativity after guerzee
died in 1992
ed whitten wrote about him and said that
he was one of the most respected members
of the physics community he said that
faiza's scientific work is marked with
remarkable originality and elegance as
well as intellectual courage he never
hesitated to pick problems that were not
fashionable he worked at them in depth
planting seeds that in some cases
developed into whole branches of our
discipline he continues that subsequent
attempts to understand phaser's work on
the su-6 symmetry led to the
introduction of the colour degrees of
freedom of quarks
edwitton continued to describe fazer as
a very cultured man
one that you could have very deep
discussions with on the topics of music
poetry
novels and paintings
in short on essentially any subject of
depth and beauty
i hadn't known about phaser gase until
recently
and so i hope sharing his story helps a
few more people to know about him but
also to provide a bit of motivation for
turkish students especially studying for
tough exams
but i also find his story to be a
reminder to stay well-rounded
physics after all is about the world
around us and understanding it
not just about passing exams
thanks short form and thank you for
watching this video a special shout out
to today's patreon cats of the day leo
and misha
[Music]
you